[Music]
don't ask if you don't want to know yes
Selena Gomez asked The Tick Tock filter
one burning question why am I single and
her reaction is just as hilarious as the
answer
[Music]
yikes Selena jokingly captioned the
viral video quote well that's rude Tick
Tock and I'm sure her very famous exes
would agree I'm looking at you Justin
Bieber and the weekend but as we know
the Heart Wants What It Wants
[Music]
now this Tick Tock seemingly confirms
Selena's relationship status as single
despite all the romance rumors this year
so far she's been romantically linked to
Jeremy Allen White
Zayn Malik and Drew Taggart of The
Chainsmokers but it's not the first time
she's focused fun at dating on social
media posting this hilarious Tick Tock
in June
I'm just a little high maintenance
but I'll love you so much
and she kind of confirmed tick tock's
assessment of why she's single while
hosting SNL last year I just want to put
it out universe that I'm manifesting
love and I would like to say that I'm
looking for my soulmate but at this
point I will take anyone
[Music]